thank you very much thank you very much
I know it's an exciting time
very exciting tomorrow is April Fool's
Day are you planning something I'd like
to propose there today when we try to
fool people by telling some outrageous
lie all right Trump calls it tweeting oh
we tell you he can try to tweet his way
out of this Russia story but this [ __ ]
ain't going anywhere
the Cold War remember the Cold War well
it is back with one small difference the
old Cold War the White House was on our
side I mean there's so many strands and
smoke to this Russia connection but I
guess the big headline this week is
Michael Flynn we had him on our show I
don't know why he came here but he did
he was the national security adviser for
a hot minute and he he is asking for
immunity to sing
cannot wait to hear what he has to sing
but this is Atman muted this the guy who
led the chance of the Convention Locker
up and he also said anyone asking for
immunity is probably guilty so you know
what Mike
if you think Hillary's a [ __ ] try karma
what no this Russia story thank God
congressman Devin Nunez is on the case
have you seen this guy the dumbest thing
to come out of California since
Dianetics I leave now
last week Nunez who's head of the House
Intelligence Committee which almost
cruel to give him that title he went
behind the back of the committee you saw
this to run over the White House to back
up Trump's bogus claim that will buyer
Obama wire tempted Trump asked him to do
a job he did it the bad news he lost all
his credibility the good news he just
won the apprentice but okay cuz I was
laughing this week we found that the
information that Nunez told the White
House he learned at the White House
that's right nunu says he needed to go
to the White House to tell them what he
learned from them the day before from
three White House staffers who told
Nunez this thing I just told you come
back tomorrow and tell us
these people are such clowns you know
the person in the whole [ __ ] eco
sphere of Trump I respect the most
Melania the old the only one with this
common sense to say [ __ ] this I'm
staying in New York I don't want to go
anywhere near this dumpster fire
and speaking of dumpster fires this is
so sad but you know when your elections
have consequences this week Trump
ordered the EPA to dismantle all of
Obama's efforts to combat global warming
mileage standards for cars gone banned
the use of the phrase you can't even say
climate change anymore around the White
House signed an executive order he was
with all the coal mining executives and
the coal miners oh we're going to bring
back Kol they're going to bring back
your jobs what the [ __ ] is it with Trump
and coal miners did did they have a
video of him getting pissed on
holy when Obama was you know channeling
money and funds to green energy
companies Republicans were always saying
oh he's picking winners yeah at least he
was picking winners from the future not
picking winners from the 19th century
it's like saying we got to get those
Blockbuster Video clerks back on back to
work but I got to get them back in this
door so upset my tie is crooked I decide
I mean even corporations
yes corporations are speaking out
against Trump's climate policy Levi's
staples the gap Exxon I'm not killing
and Minette Eminem's said it's gotten so
bad our product melts in your hand
Trump is also feuding with his own party
you know the freedom caucus used to be
the tea party now it's the freedom
caucus they're the ones who scuttled his
health care bill last week oh man
they're there they're at loggerheads and
the freedom caucus is 29 white men and
they are very conservative they do not
approve of Trump's [ __ ] grabbing they
believe in handling a woman's genitals
through legislation they are they are
very conservative I am sure they did not
like what happened yesterday in North
Carolina you see that they repealed
their bathroom bill which restricted
transgender people from going pee at
last he at last thank Almighty we can
pee at last but here's my favorite story
of the week you know remember when Trump
said about health care nobody knew
nobody knew it was okay okay probably
the theme now it also applies to the
wall that they're going to build along
Mexican border nobody knew they
identified just now a new problem any
problem they just found out that 889
miles of the border is the Rio Grande
River which we share with Mexico and if
we build the wall on our side we're
giving them the whole river
oops
and yet and yet his approval rating is
still 35% i I don't know who these 35%
are but can we build a wall around them